pourquoi ces trucs existent les amis
aujourd'hui ça va pas du tout il faut
que je vous parle d'une phobie que j'ai
depuis que je suis tout petit certains
ont la phobie des vers d'autres ont la
phobie des serpents agents voix de 3com
et des petits frissons là moi j'ai peur
des d'araignée de merde je suis
hyper violent avec elle mais je
respecte pas du tout un être possédant
plusieurs pattes aux courbes démoniaque
est au poil plus nombreux que les
cheveux d'un adulte de 50 ans elle
possède plusieurs yeux mais aussi deux
crochets pour bientôt culé si jamais tu
l'énervent on va parler tous ensemble
des araignées dans quel but dans le but
de battre ma de kobe est
peut-être la vôtre du coup on sait pas
y'a aucun meilleur truc à faire pour
combattre sa phobie que d'y faire face
c'est beau ce que je dis bordel alors il
ya plusieurs araignée qui sont très
connus parce qu'elles sont
particulièrement dangereuses yal
l'araignée violoniste déjà juste son nom
elle fut extrêmement peur on dirait
qu'elle tend d'or avec son violon pour
mieux te manger c'est incroyable elle a
des grandes pattes immense qui est bien
avec cette année c'est qu'en plus d'être
extrêmement dégueulasse le venin va
attaquer des artères donc ce qui te
maintient en vie finalement été vaisseau
donc ta peau va pourrir littéralement
mec juste en disant ça je suis pas bien
donc c'est là une bonne grosse bâtarde
qui va te met mal assurez-vous
généralement temps rencontre aux
etats-unis et pas en europe donc on est
on est plutôt bien la tg narnia
domestique à aa
ça m'est vraiment pas bien bordel ça
c'est l'araignée que j'avais rencontrée
dans une vidéo il y a deux ans à chaque
fois je veux faire au lieu d'arrêter
l'ordre mash up salaire ça avait très
mal terminé pour elle alors qu'en vrai
j'aurais pas du tout du la butée avec un
produit j'aurais juste de l'apprendre et
la foute dehors mais j'avais pas le
courage vraiment et même maintenant même
si j'ai pas vers la proximité je panique
un stage et une table tu as une tasse
trésor à quoi sert cette à ce trésor
elle sert uniquement à capturer une
araignée en dessous si j'envoie une et à
la foute dehors les mâles font six à
neuf unis mettent les femelles cette
annonce est assez petit sa vie pas très
longtemps une femelle de vivre cinq ans
pardon car quand on a une chez toi elle
peut être là cinq années mon pote tu as
plus de chances de quitter l'appartement
avant elle mon gars en vrai je comprends
totalement que les gens puissent adoré
les araignées vraiment d'argent n'avait
croisé un une fois dans ma vie ça
arrivait enfin et ça à trévani mais qu
on est en colonie de motocross comme ça
on s'amuse aux ag fait une colonie de
motocross quand j'étais plus jeune on
assure des pee wee depuis 50 ou des 80
pour ceux qui avaient des bibis donc
dans ce genre de colo déjà les douches
c'est ça un peu gay tous tu vois il ya
souvent une statue rta beaucoup de
toiles d'araignées au dessus hawaiian
araignée qui se tombent dans la douche
donc on se douche et ou sans maillot et
le mec qui se
jette dessus finances l'a tué pas c'est
mon amoureuse ok un matin on fait de la
pub lic comme ça on est bien et je vois
tous mes potes qui se regroupent un
endroit qu'est ce qui se passe dit non
j'y vais et le mec avait trouvé une
araignée noire avec des taches jaunes
est et tigré comme les moustiques tigres
mais sur une araignée et on sait très
bien que tout ce qui est tigre est
généralement il faut vraiment courir
loin l'opposé eshop l'araignée comme ça
et ensuite il se fait un actif il met sa
main sous la tasse comme ça et il fait
regarder l année incroyable elle a mordu
avec ses deux crochets il a fini à
l'hôpital
voilà c'est peut-être pour ça que je
suis traumatisé des araignées ouest s
acheter ça c'était sahara jobs frelons
d'été à vérifier habitat biologie et
scalpé coupe a dit que juste ça tous les
spécialistes décrivent comme une espèce
screen offensive cela signifie qu'elle
n'est pas agressive et n'a aucune chance
de vous mordre
pourquoi il a lieu à l'hôpital
ou alors c'est un mythomane et tout ça
n'est jamais arrivé au apparemment il se
peut que ce soit une des paires frelons
et là c'est beaucoup plus grave c'est
une araignée vénère alors sks que celle
elle fait mal parce que je sais qu'il
est allé à l'hôpital le mec je vous ment
pas après l'accouplement le mal est
souvent tué puis mangé par la femelle
donc déjà deux scénarii neige antigua
son venin peut nous causer des soucis
s'il s'avère que la personne piquée est
allergique à son venin bah écoutez bas
il était peut-être allergiques alors
tout simplement parce que moi je me
souviens qu'il était très rouge et que
c'est lui gratter à balai il avait
décidé de l'emmener à l'hôpital donc ça
devait être sa bon continuons
connaissez-vous la veuve noire une très
bonne a règné cela elle est incroyable
l'avenant vous la connaissez sûrement
sénat renier noir avec du rouge sur son
corps elle est extrêmement menez meur
son venin est une petite saloperie qui
contient de la lah trop toxique ce venin
est 15 fois plus puissant que le venin
du serpent à sonnettes c'est à dire que
cette toxine à elle va faire que tu va
produire énormément de
neurotransmetteurs et les conséquences
de sa sont multiples dues à avoir de la
fièvre des sueurs froides de la pression
artérielle tu peux carrément avoir des
hallucinations être anxieux avoir peur
de mourir enfin ça c'est du délire
s'agit complètement sur ton
cerveau mais elle te tue pas tout va
bien je te tue pas d'un mec est
tellement venerque elles capturent un
serpent n'y a plus aucune limite avec
cette année il est tellement baiser il
peut rien faire ne rien faire halak et
blu dedans mes mecs je te rends compte à
quel point une toile c'est solide un
truc qui sort d'un si petit truc c'est
dingue ce qui est terrifiant avec la
veuve noire c'est qu'elle est
extrêmement dangereuse et qu'elle est
extrêmement petit elfe et 15 mm erreur
une explosion qui me rend ouf c'est
quand tu es un dîner que tu as peur j'ai
pas d'une guerre et qui attend
grand-père qui de câlins mais c'est pas
la petite bête qui va manger la grosse
salon la pure expression c'est pas parce
que c'est petit que ça va pas te démolir
quoi la morale
lugar moi un mec je fais un mètre
soixante dix mais les mecs darwin 90 il
se méfie de ouf de moins ils savent que
je suis on passe à un échelon alors là
je vous parle d'araignée mégarde cornes
en vrai juste l'araignée de base je ne
connais pas son nom mais c'est celle où
les pâtes sont extrêmement fine et son
corps c'est juste un point un tout petit
point g parce qu'il est à renier ses
narines et bien basique qu'il ya dans
tous les foyers du monde juste salle
elle me met pas bien mener à bien l oms
est passée une poussière d'un tee shirt
du sénat renier sa gay phurba c'est
celle là regardez on la connaît bien
voilà c'est vraiment ça sauf que là il
joue ma mort en vrai c'est vraiment
minuscule quoi c'est un folk ça
s'appelle voilà elle craint le froid
elle peut pas survivre en dehors de nos
habitations c'est pour ça qu'on les
trouve tout le temps dans nos maisons la
présence de cette araignée dans nos
foyers très bénéfique pour l'homme car
malgré sa taille elle ne craint aucun
insecte ni même les otaries n'est
qu'elle n'hésite d'ailleurs pas à
attaquer durant les mois ou les proies
se font rares on a même constaté
qu'elles tuent et des araignées
dangereuse pour l'homme comme la tg
narnia agrestis sculpteur c'est cette
année là qu'est le mec avait sauvé dans
la douche à l'époque oui vous ai dit
qu'on était emmailloté pas ok le mec est
un faux mais parce qu'à l'époque il
m'avait expliqué ça justement fm élèves
et les mecs ces derniers sont trop
gentils elles font elles sont trop
bénéfique pour nous elles tuent les
moustiques et autres insectes qui
passent par là mais elles vont jamais
vous attaquer donc prenez les couach
avait pas alors on va passer à
l'araignée suivante mais une petite info
cool
rappelons que les araignées ne voit rien
à plus de 2 cm vous savez je savais pas
du tout tu vois ce genre d'info ça fait
plaisir c'est à dire que quand leurs
aînés elle est là et que tu fais ça te
voit pas donc techniquement tu es pas
mal la grande majorité des cas de
morsures sont causés par la présence de
ces araignées dans des vêtements laissé
à terre dans des chaussures ou dans des
lits dont les draps sont restés à terre
trop longtemps les personnes qui ont fui
ces textiles ou ses chaussures coince
l'araignée qui paniquent et ce même
ordre au quelle horreur oh j'ai
misé plus partait en plus dit que sa
mère tuée en pleine paranoïa mondiale la
plus incroyable des araignées vous en
avez sûrement entendu parler pourquoi l
incroyable parce que déjà elle te
démonte un la tarentule géante du
sri-lanka j'en ai pas entendu ben
tarentule on connaît tarentule géante
votre façon j'ai rarement une tarentule
ces géants comme tu t'imagines à quoi il
ressemble en la elle se fond dans
la masse
allez balin franchement elle est mal
j'avoue elle est belle elle est colorée
et où on dirait on a envie de la voir
pour noël tu sais enfin pendant deux
minutes un scorpion est l'attaqué un
scorpion le professeur des voyages quand
il ya des gens aussi qu'on perd des
scorpions mais finalement est-ce campion
c'est un mix entre un crabe une araignée
pour moi oh il est mort
oh le suspense il est morte
elle va y aller d'un coup
oh en tout cas elle est immense
donc on peut monter sur elle et s'en
servir comme monture c'est incroyable à
ya une veuve noire en europe tient lé
présent la plupart du temps en europe
surtout autour du bassin méditerranéen
les von arx mozart n'est dangereuse car
leur venin attaque le système nerveux
bah oui ces petites saloperies enfin bon
mec clairement tu vois une araignée
noire avec un q aussi énorme et des
points rouges sur douze parties au
moment où tu peux jouer au touriste
heures sur son dos il ya un bon problème
l'araignée chameau qu'est ce que c'est
que ça à la saloperie haut mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette créature du des
manques ses impressionnantes qu'elles y
sert véritable tronçonneuse sont capable
de broyer la carapace d'un scorpion
mais c'est la terminaison qu'hollande de
cp vips alpes qui constitue l' arme la
plus redoutable dépourvue de poils il se
colle à la proie pour l'attraper et ne
plus la lâcher
olalala à la déception de 713 incroyable
il s'est accroché dans mes mecs il ya
vraiment des animaux qu'on était design
et pour la mère d autres quoi
c'est vraiment ou l'araignée des sables
alors elle c'est une petite je
connais pourquoi puisque a beaucoup de
sable chez moi c'est faux j'habite à
paris elle se plante dans le sable avant
de te démolir c'est fou mais qu'elle
tremble à pour bien ses pattes
dans le sable et elle se cache la
saloperie elle par exemple lé père
venimeuse mais elle et elle n'est pas
agressive avant que tu marches dessus
120 exprès puisqu'elle est planqué dans
le sable tu risques pas de te
l'apprendre
vient ensuite la renier loup chinoise
celle elle a fait un peu le but sur
internet parce que quand elle fait des
petits en fait t'es les stocks de son
abdomen et quand tu l'écrasent alors que
senna manque à canet petit bail à un
milliard de petites arnaques et sordel
en fait voilà elle transporte tous ces
petits sur son dos et 5 et au fait
qu'elle ait pas grande mais
regarde toutes les boutiques ya sur son
dos laissez moi vous présenter
l'araignée pense ça va nous faire du
bien dans cette unité avec des araignées
si violente qui peuvent te guérit mais
un membre de ton corps en picore
araignée port déjà havrais tous que
lanvin ça fait plaisir d'avoir une
araignée coloré car peu de style
finalement vraiment elle est trop belle
elle est plus à la mode que nous plus
mal parade en exhibant les motifs
colorés de son corps pour tenter de
gagner les faveurs de la femelle
[Musique]
aussi c'est la preuve que je trouve une
araignée minium c'est trop beau mec
c'est vraiment un de bongwha
version araignée c'est incroyable et si
elle le beauf non le po vit dedans c'est
tout elle le trac terrible ça marche pas
du tout sa danse
malgré tout elle le tue après
l'accouplement fort le mec il a fait une
danse de 20 minutes il s'est fait chier
il a tout donné il était comme ça elle
le beauf les amis il est temps de
conclure cette vidéo sur les arachnides
je suis content parce qu'en vrai ça m'a
vraiment aidé à mieux comprendre
pourquoi j'ai la peur des araignées et à
mieux assumer déjà cette peur des
araignées nous vient de la mémoire
génétique cross appel c'est ce que nous
ont transmis nos ancêtres après qu'ils
aient appris qu'une araignée c'est
vilain c'est des réflexes et un instinct
qu'on a gardé qui datent de millions
d'années que l'époque des hommes des
cavernes où ils avaient raison d'avoir
peur des araignées parce que ça pouvait
vraiment les flingues et donc si tu
avais pas peur des araignées et que tu
voulais pas d'ag hasard année elle
demandait et tu crevé et surtout qu'à
l'époque y avait pas la médecine que ya
maintenant finalement c'est un héritage
de nos ancêtres qui sont morts à cause
d'une araignée et il nous aide à
survivre dans ce monde de brutes
je pense pas que c'est un traumatisme
qui vient l'enfance ou l'adolescence
perso j'ai vu que très peu d'araignée
dans ma vie elles n'ont jamais attaqué
je me suis jamais fatigué par une
araignée de là pourquoi j'aurais la
phobie d'un truc qui m'a jamais attaqué
c'est bizarre je pensais que c'était
parce que je les comprenais pas mais ça
peut pas que venir de là je les
comprends toujours pas parfaitement je
comprends mieux après cette vidéo mais
j'en aurais encore peur mais au-delà de
ça au-delà de ça même si on a encore
peur ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'une
araignée
elle voit pas plus de 2 cm à partir de
là tu es bien après ça se passait
vraiment vrai mais bon voilà je pense
qu'on a très très peur alors qu en fait
y'a pas tant de raisons de ce fichier de
sujets parce qu'en france il ya
normalement pas d'araignée aussi
dangereuse que la venant et que la
violoniste celle qu'on a vue puisque
c'est pas sa région natale du tout
ensuite une araignée est la même pas
conscience qu'elle est sur un être
vivant fait pour réalité totalement
énorme elle a même pas de raison de
mordelles pourra même pas de bouffée
derrière ça sert à rien sauf si elle se
sent en danger en bas moi j'avais envie
de parler des années avec vous servant
une phobie et depuis je suis tout jeune
et vraiment ça me rend mal quand il a
régné je suis pas bien même si elle est
très petite quoi à présent je les
comprends mieux donc j'aurai moins peur
donc je pourrais je pourrais aussi du
comment débarrasser sans avoir à les
tuer ce qui est vraiment nul
amy arachnophobes j'espère que tout
comme moi vous allez mieux je suis
patient mais j'espère je veux dire le
retour d'une prochaine vidéo j'espère
quand même ça vous aura aidé sur un
technophobes succès avec nos filets bien
apprenez nous des choses basiques dites
nous dans les commentaires des trucs moi
je suis chaud ça va m'aider c'est hyper
cool je vous dis à bientôt une prochaine
vidéo portez vous bien
[Musique]
ça